hey guys welcome back to another video
and today is going to be very special
because it is the release of season 2
meaning the Centurion and the shinobi
have been released today so I'm going to
be doing a video on the movesets and
showing you what exactly they do look
like and I'm going to show you their
outfits and then I'm going to give you
my overall opinion on what that
character happens to you know what my
opinions are the character if they're
worth it or not so I'm going to do a
practice with bot Isaac here kind of
just chillin we're going to go over the
move set so let's start with the first
one is be charged heavy if you do here
button clicking in the background I do
apologize I haven't really gotten so
that fixed yet so the charged heavy is
just a hold right trigger or hold the
heavy button you just have a normal
light and a normal heavy but this is the
charged heavy so jump in the air kind of
stabbed his next three chains are three
lights two lights and a heavy and then
two heavies which are lights light light
and then light light heavy and I'm heavy
and a heavy the cool thing about this
character though is that according to
what I've been hearing is that you can
actually end a combo with a a charged
heavy which will make the attack on
blockable like this light light and then
a charged heavy will make the thing
unblockable he does have a non guarded
or a non guard mode attack which is egos
fury which is this I'm going to jump in
the air with some hyper armor he also
has the variation too which is a dash
forward and an RT which you can do in
guard mode which is this jump in the air
he also has the Legion kick which is
just dash forward and guard break this
can be combo'd in multiple different
moves such as the jab or the charged jab
or some of the jab combos he has a
couple other things I'm going to show
you like the quick throw
like this grab little throw let's back
up a bit so it's light and then guard
break and then he'll throw you get off
this [ __ ] wall so once again it's a
light with a guard break and it'll throw
you a couple distances I bet you can
combo into that he also has the lion's
roar ability which is a guard break and
then a triple unblockable kind of like
peacekeepers but it has to be time just
like peacekeepers and but it doesn't do
bleed damage it only just drains their
stamina a shit-ton so those are really
some of the moves I've been hearing that
he's a very mix up intensive meaning you
can go let's say for example you do the
the jumping one which is RT going to
their guard break because the throw
right there it's kind of hard to explain
without me just straight-up showing you
I'll probably do some duals of this
character kind of just like some random
duel so you can understand how this
character plays later on this weekend
when I get to play some duals
but one of the combos that I've noticed
you can do are be this
and that which is the jab combo which is
RT X and then a heavy guard break into a
light he also has the charged jab which
is a heavy and then holding X and then
he has the regular jab which is a heavy
into just a regular guard break so this
that's the jab
and this is the charged jab it's like a
longer one and knocks him over kind of
like wardens shoulder bash it's the you
know you can hold it the lot of damage
but you can also use a light attack in
there so let's see if we can not pull
this off here light attack some of the
few things that he has is with the
where's the attack the legion kick is if
you have the legion kick and i can't
really show to you because Isaac doesn't
really run out of stamina too often here
but you can do the legion kick and then
which will throw them up which will
knock them over like this and then
that'll lead into more combos but a lot
of stamina you can jump a far distance
and kind of jump on their back sort of
way and they're going to do a huge stab
but anyway those are some of the move
sets I will show you some of their
outfits in a bit and but I will I will
show you some of their outfits and then
we'll kind of explain if this character
seems worth it as if just a first
impression so I'll see you when that's
over
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anyway guys that's really it though for
the outfits in my opinion though I do
like some of the elite and mythic
outfits they do look very nice and
stylish I do like the way you be soft
designed them for the way the character
works and operates though my chin my
honest opinion I feel like he's going to
be the warlord and warden baby or the
Ken say he's the Ken say that can't say
should have been is what I've been
hearing he has a lot of mix-ups he's
basically can be on tiered with radar
now with all of his mix ups and once
again this is first impression I'm going
to be playing a [ __ ] ton more of him so
I can get some of the mix ups correctly
because as you could tell that was just
pure a sympathetic of what the [ __ ] I
was just showing you but once I get
these duels done and once these videos
are over I'm going to be fine - it's on
like I said with both the characters so
you can learn some of their move sets
and then we can explain I can explain
you if they're worth it that was one of
the video ideas I had was - after like a
week of playing decide if they're worth
the 15000 steal for you non season pass
players I'm still looking out for you
guys because it's going to be the end
and then hopefully in the next hour - I
will have the shinobi videos so I'll see
you all then